goku quiere tener más de 9000
comentarios en sus vídeos de youtube él
recibe el mismo número de comentarios
por cada vídeo de gatos que sube y
también el mismo número de comentarios
por cada vídeo de perros que sube y eso
es algo sorprendente el tener
exactamente el mismo número de
comentarios por cada vídeo de gatos que
sube y también por cada vídeo de perros
que sube en la siguiente desigualdad se
representa el número de vídeos de gatos
y de representa el número de vídeos de
perros que goku debería subir para
lograr su meta 750 multiplicado por el
número de vídeos de gatos más 450
multiplicado por el número de vídeos de
perros todo esto debe ser mayor que 9000
de acuerdo con la desigualdad cuántos
comentarios se obtiene por cada vídeo de
gatos y cuántos comentarios obtiene por
cada vídeo de perros veamos si podemos
comprender qué es lo que está sucediendo
en esta desigualdad para poder responder
a esta pregunta
tener más de 9000 comentarios y aquí
vemos que efectivamente todo esto debe
ser mayor a 9000 mayor a los 9000
comentarios así que podemos ver esto
como la cantidad de comentarios que él
recibe en sus vídeos y ya que tenemos un
número x ce pues suponemos que si se es
el número de vídeos de gatos y este
número por si y queremos que se
representa el número de vídeos de gatos
esta cantidad 750 por c es el número de
comentarios que él recibe por cada vídeo
de gatos así que por cada vídeo de gatos
él va a recibir 750 comentarios
si tengo se número de vídeos de gatos y
cada uno de ellos va a tener exactamente
la misma cantidad de comentarios que son
750 comentarios pues voy a tener 750
porsche que son los comentarios que
corresponden a todos mis vídeos de gatos
oa todos los vídeos de goku de gatos así
que cada vídeo de gatos tiene 750
comentarios y de forma similar cada
vídeo de perros va a recibir 450
comentarios y si sumamos ambos vamos a
tener el número total de comentarios en
el canal que deben ser mayor que 9000
bueno si el total de los comentarios de
los vídeos de perros es de 450 por d
quiere decir que está recibiendo 450
comentarios por cada uno de los vídeos
de perros que sube 450 comentarios por
vídeo multiplicado por el número de
vídeos de perros que sube y esto nos da
el total de los comentarios
correspondiente a los vídeos de los
perros así
recibe 450 comentarios por vídeo de
perros puede óculo gran su meta si sube
8 vídeos de gatos y 7 vídeos de perros
pensemos en esto 8 vídeos de gatos y 7
vídeos de perros si tenemos 750 por 8
que son los vídeos de gatos
y los sumamos a 450 que multiplica a 7
vídeos de perros será esto mayor que
y lo pongo con signos de interrogación
porque no sé si eso se va a cumplir pues
vamos a evaluar esto a que va a ser
igual
veamos 700 por 8 es 5600 más 50 veces 8
va a ser 405 mil 600 más 400 va a ser
igual a 6000
si sube 8 vídeos de gatos 750 x 8 nos va
a dar 6000 comentarios sólo de los
vídeos de los gatos y ahora tenemos 450
x 7 400 x 7 va a ser 2 mil 850 por 7 va
a ser 350 si sumamos 2800 más 350 nos va
a dar nos va a dar 3 mil 150 veamos es
correcto esto vamos a hacer la operación
que damos que son 2 mil 800 más 400 por
7 es 2 mil 850 por 7 es igual a 350 los
sumamos 00 55 83 es once llevamos una
sin tres mil 156 mil tres mil ciento
cincuenta sin duda es mayor que nueve
mil
es mayor que 9000 esto de aquí es 9 mil
150 que es mayor que 9000 esto se cumple
y la respuesta después de goku lograr su
meta si sube 8 vídeos de gatos y 7
vídeos de perros pues la respuesta es sí